24-річна Олена Сьогодні вперше стане
донором крові перед цим дівчина два дні
дотримувалася спеціальної
дієтила не їла тому що банани не їли
алкогольні вживала Я думала що можна
їсти і взагалі перед тим як звати кров
чи Ось я так думала Але виявилось що
потрібно поснідати просто і раніше якось
хотіла до цього долучитися але якось я
не знала що куди йти а тут мене
виявилось що колега кудись дає і я
думала значить треба в неї розпитати за
порадою Олена прийшла сюди у Київський
центр служби крові через півгодини
фінальних аналізів дівчина у кріслі
доноражали почекали трішки знову піджали
ну про хворобу питали які в мене там є
можливо хронічні яке це почуваю тиск
віряли король з пальці брали на аналіз
сьогодні так людей не знаю чи завжди
стільки але так немає донори з досвідом
як от Олексій кажуть найбільше людей тут
було 24 лютого
не змогли постояли потім сказав що все
нема Чому не було можливості багато
прийнятий всіх хоча б якось допомогти
просто хтось був воєнкоматі когось не
взяли Там хтось не пройшов хтось не
попав в ну вирішили так допомагати
взагалі країні військовому всім до людей
до війни проіснував сім років і було
зареєстровано кількість людей 45 тисяч
перших чотири дні війни з 24 по 28
лютого в нашій базі плюс 25 тисяч людей
з'явилося Тобто це
таке величезне бажання наблизити нас до
перемоги кількість донорів які ми
відслідковуємо в цифрах на 60% виросла
потреба більша вона значно більша
керівниця проєкту донор.ua за допомогою
якого реєструють охочих здати кров
пояснює ще до повномасштабної війни в
Україні був сталий дефіцит донорів
Втричі менше за норму яку рекомендує
ВООЗ 30 донорів на тисячу населення А
нині в умовах війни аби вчасно
забезпечувати кров'ю та її компонентами
тих хто цього потребує і цивільних і
військових у резерві центрів крові мало
би бути два мільйони донорів нині їх 100
тисяч
виставляємо потреби зараз у нас не
більше потреба вперше позитивні другій
негативні та в четвертій негативні групи
крові запаси цієї але все одно ми
потребуємо донорів Тобто всі груп крові
завідувачка відділення у центрі служби
крові лікарні Охматдит розповідає багато
людей відкладають донорство через хибні
уявлення про сам процес це безпечно ми
використовуємо одноразові стерильні всі
там розходні матеріали і сама до нація
крові наприклад триває тільки
всього-на-всього 5-10 хвилин і питаючи
це больше ну кожного напевно брали
аналіз з вени це те саме крім до нації
крові наші є до нації тромбоконцентратом
і тут вже довше процедура середня
тривалість цієї процедури біля години ще
один з міфів що не може замко снідати
можна снідати але просто є багато
обмежень можна будь-яка каша але без
масла без молока там відварне воно про
м'ясо відварене воно прориба можна
солодкий чай знежирне печиво там з
фруктів можна яблука стати донорами
можуть не всі є протипоказання
медичні інфекційні паразитарні психічні
захворювання хвороби крові серця та
онкологія після перенесених операцій
переливання крові та татуювань здавати
кров не можна протягом року в мене була
заборона бо було
хірургічне втручання Сьогодні усі кого
допустили до процедури можуть стати
донорами двома способами перший здати
компоненти крові тромбоцити які
допомагають людям з їхньою нестачею
зокрема при захворюваннях крові другий
метод здати цільну кров яку потім також
розділяють на складники плазму та
еритроцити вони життєво необхідні
пацієнтам з крововтратами після забору
цільного крові вона ще проходить через
фільтр пакет уже лейкофільтрованої крові
ставиться на загрузку на центрування
розділення
на холодильниках 4 градус постійно
контролюється ця температура без скріву
консервування тобто заморозки на два або
три роки свіжі еритроцити можуть
зберігатися до 42 діб тромбоцити до 5
діб плазма до трьох до лікарень кров
частіше доставляють за конкретної
потреби із запасу а до лінії фронту в
умовах війни возять у спеціальних
холодильних камерих двічі на тиждень аби
завжди був резерв донор.ua в тому числі
і транспортує крок з усієї України в
прифронтовій лікарні ми повністю
закриваємо
північно-східну Південний
фронт скажемо так де відбувається бойові
дії тому навіть якщо ви проживаєте у
Львові на Закарпатті чи в інших містах
де вам здавалося б що немає активних
бойових дій ви все одно діють здавайте
кров тому що ви станете точно тою
частинкою життя яка поїде до
прифронтових лікарень Ніхто з донорів
знає кому дістанеться їхня кров хочуть
допомогти будь-кому Хто цього потребує
будь-кому кому потрібно допомога
моя кофе кожна людина для себе повинен
знайти якусь собі мотивацію чому їй це
потрібно Чому вона хоче це зробити
[музика]